wir beginnen heute mit der ard ist
folgen dann auch noch die linkspartei
und die fdp die
regierungspressekonferenz dem feld heute
auf dem podium haben platz genommen
die spitzenkandidaten der ard alice
weide und alexander gauland und die
parteivorsitzende jörg merten und frauke
petry herzlich willkommen
vermeidet sie an das wort guten morgen
sehr geehrte damen und herren vielen
dank dass sie heute so zahlreich
erschienen sind
ja wir haben ein sehr gutes wahlergebnis
geholt als alternative für deutschland
das hat dann selber überrascht wir haben
nicht mit einem so hohen wahlergebnis
gerechnet laut der letzten amtlichen
zählungen liegen wir jetzt bei 13
prozent und sind dementsprechend
drittstärkste kraft wir freuen uns sehr
über dieses ergebnis was auch ein ganz
klarer wählerauftrag ist nämlich als
oppositionspartei im 19 deutschen
bundestag zu werten und eben auch den
wähler auftrag wahrzunehmen und zwar als
partei im bundestag die bundesregierung
zukünftig auch zu kontrollieren wir
haben gesehen dass das in den
vergangenen jahren sträflich
vernachlässigt wurde das eben die
legislative die exekutive kontrolliert
es wurde alles durch gewunken nicht
einmal diskutiert und bis heute ist
beispielsweise auch die
flüchtlingspolitik der deutschen
bundesregierung nicht einmal auf einer
rechtlichen grundlage
dies werden wir ändern das werden wir
diskutieren und bestehen für eine
konstruktive oppositionsarbeit im 19ten
deutschen bundestag und wir freuen uns
auf den wählerauftrag und bedanken uns
für das vertrauen der wählerinnen und
wähler die uns dieses mandat gegeben
haben vielen dank ja ich will gar nicht
viel hinzufügen man kann das ja heute
auch in den zeitungen lesen natürlich
ist es erstmal unser erfolg
es ist auch natürlich der misserfolg der
anderen ich habe heute hier in der bild
zeitung gelesen dass herr bosbach gesagt
hat ja die union hat rechts leider sehr
viel platz gelassen
und genau das ist es die union vertritt
keine inhalte mehr ich bin noch in einer
cdu und groß geworden
die völlig anders war aber leider gilt
die unfähigkeit das land vernünftig zu
regieren auch für die spd was soll man
von einer partei halten
bei der herr gabriel in der
außenminister auf der regierungsbank mit
refugees werk am button sitzt und drei
tage vor der wahl sagt dieses war aber
falsch die flüchtlingspolitik
was sollen menschen von solchen parteien
halten insofern ja ich weiß da ist ein
großer vertrauensvorschuss auch in uns
gegeben worden wir werden uns mühe geben
den zu erhalten
aber es kommt eben auch sehr viel auf
die anderen an
wir wollen im bundestag haben wir
deutlich gesagt eine klare opposition
sein
der bundestag muss wieder ein die der
resonanzboden für die gesellschaftlichen
fragen in diesem lande sein das ist ja
nicht mehr gewesen
ich habe deutlich gemacht gestern und
auch in den balg umgebungen
ich erinnere mich als junger mann noch
an die großen debatten zwischen einem
mann und der adenauer über
wiederaufrüstung westbindung
nato-mitgliedschaft später ostpolitik
wenn sie mir eine vernünftige platte in
diesem bundestag
witzigerweise hat herr bosbach genau
dasselbe gesagt nennen sie mir eine
vernünftige debatte über russland
sanktionen über eine spionageaffäre über
euro rettung gibt es nicht mehr es wird
abgelegt wir wollen in den bundestag
wieder eine debattenkultur die dann auch
dazu führt dass die bevölkerung weiß
welche entscheidung und warum getroffen
werden und wer dazu steht das ist unsere
aufgabe und die werden wir erfüllen
danke
auch petri bitteschön
guten morgen meine damen und herren die
fdp ist nach viereinhalb jahren floss
existenz in den deutschen bundestag
eingezogen das ist ein riesenerfolg für
die debattenkultur in deutschland bei
einem ergebnis von knapp 13 prozent und
der ersten position unter den parteien
in meinem bundesland in sachsen wo wir
es war ganz knapp aber am ende doch vor
der cdu
tatsächlich den wahlsieg als stärkste
kraft errungen haben
all dieser geben sie zeigen uns dass die
bürger eine neue kraft in diesem land
dringend suchen und sie ja auch aus
verzweiflung vor den großen parteien cdu
und spd aber durchaus auch aus hoffnung
auf eine neue kraft die afg in den 19
deutschen bundestag gewählt haben
opposition in der ersten legislatur im
letzten ein parlament zu sein ist eine
große aufgabe auch das haben wir immer
gesagt dass wir ein hersteller
realistisch bleiben wollen mehr als
opposition ist es in den ersten vier
jahre nicht aber der anspruch an die
oppositionsrolle der ist für mich ganz
klar die regierungsübernahme in 2021
vorzubereiten denn die trendwende ist
2017 politisch noch nicht wenn wir sehen
dass nun über eine jamaika koalition
zwischen cdu fdp und grünen gesprochen
wird wenn sie denn zustande kommt oder
am ende doch die spd sich eine neue
gruppe teuer erkaufen lässt
insofern ist mein inhaltlicher anspruch
dass wir endlich programmatische inhalte
via flyer in ihren beiden programmen sei
2016 präsentiert nun auch personell
vernünftig untersätzen damit beim wähler
eben dieser angebote ankommen und nicht
wie leider in der vergangenheit auch
selbstverschuldet abseitige position die
dann auch durch ihre verstärkung meine
damen und herren und oftmals auch durch
falsche und verkürzte zitate ein bild
von der afg zeichen dass mit der
realität eben nicht immer viel gemein
hat und in diesem zusammenhang möchte
ich einmal ausdrücklich vor allen
wahlkämpfern der ard die allermeisten
waren im gegensatz zu den anderen
parteien ehrenamtliche wahlkämpfer von
ganzem herzen bedanken weil sie
gemeinsam mit all denjenigen die durch
das land gereist sind diesem wahlerfolg
als möglich gemacht haben
lassen sie mich noch ein letztes wort
sagen weil ich glaube dass wir in diesem
tag auch offen sein sollten damit dass
des inhaltlichen dissens in der afg gibt
ich finde wir sollten diesen nicht tot
schweigen weil das genau das was sie von
der gesellschaft auch fordern dass eine
offene kontroverse geführt wird die akte
von 2013 hat den klaren anspruch
vertreten und so war es auch bis 2015 am
ende schnell regierungsfähig zu werden
das ist weiterhin mein anspruch eine
anarchische partei wie es in den
vergangenen wochen das eine oder andere
mal zu hören war die die afg sei die
kann der opposition erfolgreich sein
aber sie kann eben dem wähler kein
glaubwürdiges angebot für eine
regierungsübernahme machen und das ist
der grund meine damen und herren unter
anderem einem anspruch verbunden dass
ich aktiv gestalten möchte und eben
realpolitik im guten sinne einer
konservativen politik machen werde
für mich nach langer überlegung zu
entscheiden dass ich der fdp fraktion im
deutschen bundestag nicht angehören
werden
meine damen und herren ich bitte um
verständnis dass ich dazu jetzt auch
keine weiteren fragen beantwortet sie
haben sicherlich noch viele fragen ich
werde im foyer auch noch für wenige
nachfragen bereitstehen ich möchte mich
bei meinen kollegen bedanken bei an die
zweite war alexander gauland und bei
gebäuden und werde jetzt diesen raum
verlassen
dankeschön
kein pardon das alte profi
das finde ich ein faires verhalten hier
auch gegenüber den kollegen leid aber
sie nutzen das forum der
bundespressekonferenz mit dem welt
versetzen und verschwinden dann also
insofern missbilligen wir dieses
verhalten ausdrücklich
jetzt kriege ich jetzt das so also
nochmal ich missbillige als vorstand
bundespressekonferenz ihre dieses
verhalten ausdrücklich die
bundespressekonferenz hier als forum in
dieser form
ich möchte mal sagen zu missbrauchen
dann gehen wir weiter gekommen zu fragen
zwei vorbereitungen seien sie so gut
auch wenn ich jetzt hat mit petrochina
in aller mir eigenen bescheidenheit
wollten bitte sie haben das wort
zunächst einmal darf ich mich immer mal
im namen meiner partei bei ihnen
entschuldigen sie haben völlig recht
das ist so nicht vorgesehen das ist auch
mit uns nicht abgesprochen gewesen
ich bitte sie die entschuldigung
anzunehmen ich habe meine damen und
herren ich glaubte nach der gerade
geplatzten bombe von wäre ich auch keine
kenntnis hatte kann ich eigentlich jetzt
nichts substanzielles mehr beitragen was
ich ihnen mit auf dem weg geben wollte
ich fasse mich bewusst ganz kurz wir
haben das glaube ich unstrittig einen
großartigen erfolg errungen und das ist
der vierzehnte erfolg hintereinander
unserer partei wir haben die letzten 13
landtagswahlen gewonnen wir sind jetzt
mal hintereinander in nationale
parlamente eingezogen
das ist keiner partei vor der
alternative für deutschland bisher
gelungen dass wir dessen ungeachtet ein
gieriger auch in sind wie mein freund
alexander geiger das zuweilen gesagt hat
haben sie vor wenigen sekunden hier im
saal erlebt dessen ungeachtet es ist ein
fest der demokratie so sehen wir das was
wir erlebt haben die wahlbeteiligung ist
gestiegen dafür dass wir sicherlich
unseren anteil an
das ist bis jetzt wenig gewürdigt worden
das ist gut das ist gut für unser land
wir haben auch mehr politische vielfalt
nun endlich wieder im bundestag wir
haben wir konservative werden eine
freiheitliche opposition die gab es
bislang nicht
das ist sehr sehr wichtig alexander
gauland alle zweifel haben eigentlich
alles wesentliche gesagt haben ja auch
in ihrem grandiosen wahlkampf schon sehr
deutlich gemacht das gibt jetzt eine
richtig vitale opposition im bundestag
und das wird unserem land
tun das ist unsere aufgabe wir werden
keine faulen kompromisse machen
wir werden auch nicht das tun was manche
vermuten ich hörte gestern wurde auch
selbst gefragt wollen wir da jetzt
krawall machen oder ähnliches überhaupt
nicht in unserem sinne machen wenn den
landesparlamenten auch nicht wenn wir im
bundestag nicht machen wir werden eine
sehr harte aber stets auch konstruktive
und faire oppositionsarbeit machen und
auch den anderen parteien anbieten
lassen was damit einmal wenden habe sie
haben sicherlich viele fragen kann ich
mir vorstellen wir stehen über diese
fragen jetzt zur verfügung
dann kommen wir zu fragen als erstes die
vorbemerkung fragerecht in der
bundespressekonferenz hans zunächst nur
die mitglieder der bundespressekonferenz
und des vp es je nach zeitverlauf öffne
ich das dann noch später wir haben genau
eine stunde zeit ist kurz vor um 10
die erste frage hat der kollege wenig
oppositionspartei dass sie die regierung
durch die manege ein bisschen treibt
geschenkt aber sie haben gesagt sie
wollen sich unser land und unser volk
zurückholen
darauf gab es viele reaktionen ich habe
aus meinem persönlichen umfeld einige
leute gehabt die mich gefragt haben wo
hin um himmels willen wilders' mich
zurückholen und wo will er mich
zurückholen und warum ich will nicht
zurückgeholt werden und angefüllt kam
raus die hatten angst vor dem was sie
gesagt haben ich möchte gerne von ihnen
wissen ist ihnen bewusst dass die
bürgerinnen und bürgern keine politiker
keine journalisten ganz normale bio
deutsche dass die angst vor dem haben
ist das vielleicht sogar teil der
strategie und wer ist dass ihr volk bin
ich das auch wohin wollen sie mich ihr
volk zurück und wo ist das was ist das
also debatten müssen hart geführt werden
und ich habe vorhin gesagt das ist
inzwischen nicht mehr üblich in
deutschland und deswegen ist es falsch
niemand würde sich im britischen
parlament darüber aufregen wenn man sagt
die regierung werden wir sagen dass wir
uns bei uns schon drüber aufregen und
dass sie sogar sagen die menschen haben
angst kann ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
verstehen da stimmt irgendetwas nicht
mit unserer demokratie schauen sie sich
mal die alten debatten im bundestag an
schauen sie sich mal eine herbert wehner
und franz josef strauß an
da ist das doch völlig harmlos natürlich
muss man eine regierung jagen man muss
sie jagen in der parlamentarischen
debatte
und genau das habe ich ausdrücken wollen
und das werden wir auch machen und da
soll man bitte nicht mit irgendwelchen
angst visionen von menschen kommen darum
ging es überhaupt nicht und wir wollen
uns unser land zurückholen das steht auf
unserem wahlplakaten zum teil
es tut mir leid wir sind der meinung wir
wollen ja eine
andere politik eine million menschen
fremd in dieses land geholt nehmen ein
stück dieses landes weg und das wollen
wir als auf den ich und wir sind gewählt
worden
dafür dass wir diese politik ganz
knallhart ansprechen und deswegen habe
ich diese formulierung gebraucht dieses
wort zurückholen ist symbolisch gemeint
will sagen ich will nicht deutschland
verlieren an eine invasion von fremden
menschen aus fremden kulturen ganz
einfach nachfrage aber wer ist ihr volk
nach alle die einen deutschen pass haben
wenn ihr sie mir die gelegenheit geben
dass ganz kurz zu ergänzen uns wird dann
gerne unterstellt wir seien gegen jede
form von von migranten es ist eine grund
tatsache dass wir hier eine tief
siebenstellige zahl haben und deutlich
siebenstellige zahl an in unserer
gesellschaft integriert lebenden
migranten und es sind gerade die
übrigens die die alternative für
deutschland in besonderem maße goutieren
und auch wählen das kann ich ihnen
versichern und das werden auch die die
empirischen überprüfung des
wahlverhaltens darlegen ich rede immer
wieder mit menschen mit
migrationshintergrund die sagen das was
hier geschieht geht ganz stark auch zu
unseren lasten zu unseren voll zu
deutschland zu dem land das wir uns auch
zurückholen wollen sie weil es ein stück
weit verloren zu gehen droht und das
stück weit kann auch ein sehr großes
stück werden gehören selbstverständlich
die menschen mit migrationshintergrund
die hier leben die nicht nur einen
deutschen pass haben sondern die auch
vom herzen her deutsche sind die unsere
sprache angenommen haben die unsere
kultur angenommen haben die andere ja
bekanntlich behaupten es gäbe sie gar
nicht die hier zur wertschöpfung in
unserer gesellschaft beitragen
das sind integrale bestandteile unseres
volkes zählweise von bio solche
ansprachen dazu gehören auch menschen
die nicht bio deutschland die aber in
unserer gesellschaft angekommen sind die
gehören definitiv zu uns nicht zu uns
gehören und dass
sagt alexander gauland sehr klar die
vielen menschen die hier unberechtigt
reinkommen als glücksritter was ihnen
nicht zu verdenken ist warum sollten wir
das nicht nicht versuchen wenn ihnen die
chance gegeben wird
aber die im grunde genommen dann hier
auch massiv und das können wir nicht
übersehen sozialleistungen abgreifen die
mit gewisser als zur wertschöpfung
unserer nation nicht beitragen dazu
großenteils auch gar nicht im stande
sind
und dagegen verwahren ich rede von den
leuten die deutsche sind den pass haben
die vielleicht nicht zurückgeholt werden
wollen
darum geht's ich habe nicht einmal
flüchtlinge nicht einmal migrant gesagt
darum geht es mir da nicht mit der vg
aber ich meine das ist das ist doch
legitim
sie dürfen doch wir leben in einer
demokratie und wenn sie sagen sie haben
diese position gar nicht und empfinden
das auch nicht so dann werden sie unsere
partei nicht wählen und das ist es ist
völlig legitim und ihr gutes recht dass
haben glaube ich etwa 87 prozent der
menschen nicht getan
das ist das ist soweit völlig normal
aber es ist unsere position und dass er
mit dieser position nicht ganz alleine
stehen können sie daran sehen dass mehr
als sechs millionen menschen wenn ich es
richtig über schauer uns ihr vertrauen
bei dieser wahl geschenkt haben weil die
genau die gleiche sorge haben wir auch
die nächsten finden das vielleicht noch
kurz zur ergänzung die frage kommt oft
und ich möchte sie ihm ganz einfach
erklären was damit gemeint ist
hol dir dein land zurück dieses land
dieser staat hat die prinzipien der
rechtsstaatlichkeit verlassen
das hat angefangen bei der euro
rettungspolitik die eben jeder
rechtlichen grundlage entbehrt wir haben
in den europäischen verträgen festgelegt
die no-bail-out-klausel kein staat darf
für die verbindlichkeiten schulden eines
anderen staates haften getan wird das
gegenteil alimentiert von der
bundesregierung dann haben wir eine
flüchtlingspolitik der offenen grenzen
wo jeder unkontrolliert über offene
grenzen laufen kann
wir haben ein migrantenstrom der nicht
kontrolliert ist mit hunderttausenden
von ausreisepflichtigen migranten und
auch hier und das wird jetzt schon
zigfach auch in gutachten bestätigt
entwerte diese flüchtlingspolitik dieser
2015 vollzogen wurde jeder rechtlichen
grundlage
sie ist rechts brüchig und das ist auch
ein grund warum wir
land zurückholen wollen weil wir unser
land auf die grundlagen der
rechtsstaatlichkeit und regeltreue von
gesetzen zurückholen wollen
die mit füßen getreten werden von der
cdu und von der spd in der vergangenheit
und jetzt mal gucken wie sich jamaika
verhalten wird das ist ja auch eine
absolute kakophonie dass er etwas
verheiratet wirte was überhaupt gar
nicht zusammengehörte nur um uns die
oppositionsführerschaft zu verbauen ja
in dem die spd sich jetzt so auch
etabliert das ist ganz einfach dieser
staat hat die grundlagen der
rechtsstaatlichkeit von recht und
ordnung verlassen und darum wurden hier
gewählt mit dem slogan hol dir dein land
zurück ganz einfach und ich gebe noch
eine ergänzung in zu dir geht ganz
schnell wenn selbst der
wissenschaftliche dienst des deutschen
bundestages dieser regierung und dieser
kanzlerin attestiert dass sie keine
rechtsgrundlage gehabt hat keine diesem
wissenschaftlichen dienste sind
herausragende juristen keine
rechtsgrundlage gehabt hat für die
öffnung der grenzen und die
migrationspolitik die in den letzten
zwei jahren hier gemacht wurde
dann ist das im grunde genommen eine
eine situation in der in einem
zivilisierten land eine regierung und
auch eine kanzlerin nicht mehr haltbar
ist
deswegen kommt auch dieser dieser spruch
der sehr sehr stark in diesem land
skandiert wird merkel muss weg das kommt
daher dass von dieser kanzlerin
rechtsbrüche ausgehen ohne
rechtsgrundlage unsere grenzen geöffnet
das parlament nicht beteiligt das volk
nicht beteiligt dagegen werden wir uns
wenden und wir fordern geltendes recht
ein dass es im rechtsstaat so und dass
unsere aufgabe im bundestag die nächste
frage 2
dürfen
ich hätte gerne gewußt von sie sich
beide mit verantwortlich führen für
diesen schritt
ob sie das bedauern oder vielleicht
sogar mit genugtuung erfüllt hat bauland
sie haben gesagt sie würde in anatolien
entsorgt und haben die bundes die
wehrmachtsoldaten über den grünen klee
gelobt und wollten sie haben gesagt sie
wollen mit frau petra nicht zusammen
vorsitzender der fdp sein
sie betrachten sie den schritt jetzt von
frau patrick von zehn minuten
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen war
ich wie ich wissen was warum sie diesen
schritt jetzt hier vor der
bundespressekonferenz vollzogen hat ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das dinge
sind die dazu beigetragen haben
ich muss nicht immer wiederholen das
sind die beiden sachen die mir ja auch
schon gestern vorgehalten worden sind
also ich habe deutlich gemacht dass eine
integrationsbeauftragte die nicht
integrieren kann weil sie die deutsche
kultur für mich zählt dass die
jedenfalls sich vielleicht besser in
einem land kaufen sollt aufhalten sollte
wo sie möglicherweise mehr von der
kultur versteht und ehrlich gesagt die
geschichte mit den deutschen soldaten
kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr
nachvollziehen
es war gestern mit dass frau will zu mir
und sagte ja ja sie kommen jetzt wieder
mit mit maria verdammt nochmal natürlich
komme ich mit mir daran das hat der
französische staatspräsident 95 gesagt
was ist daran in irgendeiner weise
provokativ ich habe nur wiederholt was
ein französischer staatspräsident in
einer großen rede am 8 mai 1995 gesagt
hat und dann kann ich nur sagen ich
glaube nicht dass das der grund ist dass
frau petra hier jetzt raus gegangen ist
und da wir alle drei die gründe nicht
wissen wird man die klären müssen aber
die kann ich ihnen jetzt nicht
beantworten nachfrage
das handliche 20 frauen so was gesagt
sie haben gesagt sie soll sich ein land
suchen dessen kultur sie besser versteht
legen sie ihr nahe deutschland zu
verlassen und ich verstehe jetzt sagt
dass sie sich vielleicht mal
entschuldigung falls es hat einen
deutschen pass das ist in hamburg
geboren aber sie hat auch einen
türkischen pass
und ich habe ihr empfohlen alle zeit
lang in einem land zu sein in dem sie
vielleicht von der kultur mehr verstehe
ich das habe ich in dieser rede
empfohlen ja natürlich war ist
symbolisch gemeint ist doch völlig klar
und hat nichts mit irgendwelchen
gewaltfantasien zu tun die mir zum teil
unterstellt werden nur ich kann jetzt
nicht die verbindung zur frau petri
finden das tut mir leid denn das ist
nicht der punkt der den sie mir gesagt
hat das ist der grund warum sie jetzt
gegangen ist weiß ich ja schauen sie wir
haben wir haben einen hoch engagierten
wahlkampf gemacht es ist nicht zu
übersehen dass wir einen sehr
erfolgreichen wahlkampf bestritten haben
wir haben hallen gefüllt wir unsere
wahlkampfveranstaltungen waren besser
besucht als wie alle anderen parteien
und das den erfolg sehen sie jetzt
wissen die partei mit der mit der
höchsten zuwachsrate wir haben deutlich
mehr als eine verdoppelung unseres
ergebnisses gegenüber der letzten
bundestagswahl
wir sind haben alle unsere ziele
erreicht wir sind deutlich zweistellig
geworden wir sind deutlich drittstärkste
kraft geworden die wir das angestrebt
haben und wir haben einen
spitzenkandidaten so dass sehr viel in
sehr harte arbeit dazu beigetragen hat
dass jetzt jetzt hier neben mir und es
ist sicherlich nicht hilfreich wenige
tage vor der wahl dieses
spitzenkandidaten wo in einer weise zu
attackieren die peters im interview
gegenüber der leipziger volkszeitung
getan hat warum sie das tut das müssen
sie bitte bei frau befragen
ich darf aber als als bundessprecher
meiner partei sagen dass das nicht
hilfreich ist wie auch die teilnahme
beziehungsweise die nichtteilnahme frau
geht in den letzten monaten an sitzungen
und telefonkonferenz
das des bundesvorstands wo sich fast
nicht mehr zugegen war nicht hilfreich
war
wir haben die aufgabe hier gemeinsam zu
arbeiten und wir haben als team
gearbeitet und petri ist aus diesem aus
dieser teamarbeit leider ausgeschert das
hätten wir uns auch anders gewünscht
aber wir müssen das zur kenntnis nehmen
und ich möchte das auch nicht weiter
kommentieren sie können da gerne gerne
frau kate zu befragen es ist bedauerlich
der vgt hat er hat viele gute gaben und
wenn das integrativ gelaufen wäre dann
wäre das sicherlich wünschenswert
gewesen aber es ist wie es ist und das
müsse zur kenntnis nehmen
zunächst war die zeit
ich bin trotzdem gerne nochmal auf die
inhaltlichen differenzen zurück kommen
die frau petri angesprochen hat gibt es
die und wenn ja wie sollte man mit denen
umgehen
auch dazu will ich danke erst mal für
die frage gerne etwas sagen
ich glaube dass diese inhaltlichen diese
inhaltlichen differenzen sehr stark
konstruiert sind weil ihr eine
bipolarität der partei unterstellt wird
die so nicht existiert also sozusagen
hier seien die äußersten rechtsaußen und
da seien die gemäßigten das wird ja der
realität so nicht gerecht und es wird
auch nicht dem dem verhalten vp tricks
gerecht wenn sie das design ist
praktisch die gemäßigte und wir seien
jetzt hier die wilden fundierter von
fundamental oppositionellen das mit
verlaub wissen ist ein ziemlich schräges
bild geben wir doch nicht von personen
aus gehen wir von den inhalten aus dann
haben wir viele positionen in denen wir
völlig realpolitisch arbeiten das tun
wir in den parlament in manchen klappt
das gut in anderen stigmatisiert man uns
noch stark und es gibt bereiche wo wir
wirklich fundamental oppositionelle sind
zu denen arbeiter partei gehört zum
beispiel dass wir mehr bürgerbeteiligung
fordern dass wir tatsächlich eine in
anführungsstrichen schweiz arisierung
der politik befürworten würden das heißt
wir wollen mehr direkte demokratie
das ist bei unseren derzeitigen beim
derzeitigen stand unseres landes eine
fundamental oppositionelle position aber
liebe frau diese position haben wir alle
sie werden in der ganzen
denn niemand finden der sich gegen diese
diesen programmpunkt ganz wichtigen
programmpunkt unserer partei wendet
sondern das eint uns alle
insofern haben wir überwiegend zu sagen
hat zu mehr als 90 prozent völlig real
politische positionen die andere sind
als die der etablierten parteien und das
ist ja legitim und wir haben in einigen
wenigen punkten stichwort direkte
demokratie ein anderes staatsverständnis
das könnte ihn nun wortreich erklärt
aber dann wird das jetzt im
wissenschaftlichen vortrag das gar nicht
gegenstand einer pressekonferenz sein
warum mir das haben fest steht dass die
demokratie in der schweiz deutlich
besser funktioniert als sie das bei uns
tut und das hat sehr viel damit zu tun
dass der souverän eben stärker beteiligt
ist
das wollen wir und das in der tat ist
fundamental oppositionelle position die
aber meines wissens auch eine frau petri
jederzeit geteilt hat insofern ist also
diese diese polarität eine ein konstrukt
das der realität nicht standhält
die nächste frage heute wir haben ja
jetzt den ausdruck von petri hier
gesehen interpretieren sie das auch als
auszug aus der bundestagsfraktion der
künftigen also werden wir ähnlich wie in
baden württemberg jetzt künftig zwei afg
fraktionen erleben sind sie da ich hier
papi dringlich fragen kann sind sie
bereit mit ihr weiterhin in der
künftigen bundestagsfraktion zusammen
arbeiten zu zusammenzuarbeiten und
welche rolle sehen sie für sie künftig
also wir können nicht frau petri
interpretieren bitte sehen sie uns dass
nach da wir alle drei halten wollen
frau petri ist gewählte
spitzenkandidatin von sachsen und gehört
damit zur fraktion punkt was sie jetzt
macht kann ich nicht beurteilen
mehr habe ich dazu nicht zu sagen ich
hab auch wir beide verweisen und ich
nicht darüber befinden wo petri künftig
ihren ihrer arbeit tut das ist ihre
entscheidung und die entscheidung der
fraktion aber nicht unser wir haben hier
ein ganz wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf
wir haben ganz klaren wähler auftragen
es gibt überhaupt keine zeit zu
verlieren unser fokus von alexander
gauland und mir ist die fraktionsbildung
wir haben alles vorbereitet bereits in
den letzten wochen morgen haben wir
konstituierende sitzung der der
bundestagsfraktion morgen und übermorgen
und es werden wichtige weichen gestellt
ob die wir uns jetzt fokussieren alles
andere muss hinten anstehen
wenn ich darauf hinweisen darf wir
bleiben in der bundespressekonferenz
beim deutschen ich glaube überhaupt
nicht dass diese parteien alle
vergleichbar sind und das ist überall in
europa jetzt irgendwie eine
mobilisierung von nationalistischen
parteien gebe ich bin immer sehr
skeptisch gewesen das wissen
das wissen viele die mich kennen wenn
wir irgendwelche vergleichbarkeit
anstellen er trump hat uns weder
geholfen noch geschadet weil wir andere
probleme haben als die amerikaner
frau le pens niederlage am ende hat uns
nicht geschadet weil in frankreich es
andere probleme gibt
ich habe immer oder wie beide haben
immer wieder gesagt ja es gibt eine
partei bei denen bei der einfach aus der
historischen tradition der gemeinsamen
sprache und ähnlicher überlegungen
heraus ist eine gewisse ja wie soll ich
sagen verbindungen gibt das ist die
freiheitliche partei österreichs und wir
beide es weiter und ich waren auch über
pfingsten war heinz strache die uns
immer auch kluge ratschläge gegeben
haben
aber das ist die einzige partei wo es
engere beziehung gibt alles andere sind
natürlich nationale ausformungen wie wir
eine nationale ausformung in deutschland
sind und sie sehen ja dass uns herr
trump dem von dem immer wieder gesagt
wird er habe viel mit uns zu tun gehabt
weder genutzt noch geschadet hat ich
sehe also die verbindung nicht und ich
sehe auch nicht dass ich irgendwas in
europa ändert all diesen parteien durch
uns die nächste frage herr sagurna
[Musik]
hingegeben den in sachsen sogar fast 30
also für petri sie sprechen vom wähler
auftrag ist es ihnen vor laufenden
kameras die die halbe parteiführung
weggelaufen
sie können auch wenn cvp trees motive
nicht interpretieren doch nicht hier
sitzen lassen und sagen die sie sich als
rest parteiführung da verhalten werden
ja frau petri ist man hat wenn ich ihr
verhalten richtig interpretiere zunächst
einmal nicht der verteidiger rücken
gekehrt
ich denke sie wird sich da noch weiter
erklären sie hat gesagt sie wolle dieser
fraktion nicht angehören und verliest
jetzt diese pressekonferenz das nehmen
wir erst mal zur kenntnis
jetzt sitzen wir hier mal in der
pressekonferenz sind dass wir uns intern
in unseren gremien darüber unterhalten
werden wie wir wie wir damit umgehen ist
bei ihm völlig natürlicher vorgang
das können wir aber jetzt hier nicht auf
offener bühne machen werden auch nicht
sondern darüber beraten wir in unseren
gremien
die wähler haben ihn ja auch nicht in
den gremien die stimmen gegeben sondern
gestern in einer offenen wahl sie müssen
den leuten doch sagen dass jetzt mit
dieser parteilos ist wenn die hälfte weg
von der bühne
es ist nicht die hälfte decken sondern
wenn ich es richtig sehe hat frau petri
als einzelpersonen die bühne verlassen
das macht ganz großen unterschiede wir
haben eine eine große starke und
geschlossene partei zurzeit in der vp
die offensichtlich aus gründen die sie
bitte bei ihr erforschen mögen in eine
minderheitsposition bezieht dann möge
sie das tun
das ist frau beatrice freie entscheidung
aber wir haben in der tat und danke für
den hinweis uns ist das aber auch so
bewusst einen einen wählerauftrag
erhalten von mehr als sechs millionen
menschen
der lautet im kern sacharbeit und zwar
gute sacharbeit einer vitalen
oppositionsarbeit im deutschen bundestag
zu machen
das hängt nicht von einzelnen personen
ab sondern das hängt davon ab wie stark
wir dort vertreten sind und die sauber
hier dort arbeiten und wir haben einen
auf eine fraktion von wenn ich es
richtig sehe etwas mehr als 90
abgeordneten damit kann man genau dass
du das ist unsere aufgabe der werden wir
gerecht werden
daran werden auch sie uns messen daran
müssen wir uns messen
mal die ganzen match in anbetracht der
tatsache dass im vorfeld der wahl der
wahlen auch mit harten bandagen gekämpft
wurde
innen wurde ja von verdrehten anderer
parteien vorgeworfen das mit ihrer
partei nazis in den bundestag einziehen
wie sieht dann die zusammenarbeit im
bundestag mit anbetracht dieser tatsache
und der tatsache der inneren
zerstrittenheit
wie wird die zusammenarbeit sich
gestalten und was wird ihre erste
anfrage an die bundesregierung sein
also lassen sie mich vielleicht ganz
kurz ein wort zu den nazis vorneweg
sagen und dann der rest sollte von den
anderen beiden in die sitze im bundestag
beantwortet werden
es gibt wissen sie es gibt grenzen und
diese grenzen des anstands die werden
zum teil von unseren politischen gegnern
überschritten
und wenn derlei vorwürfe kommen dann ist
es fast wie eine scharfe zurückweisung
nicht mehr getan ist dermaßen
ungeheuerlich uns etwas solches zu
unterstellen
und wissen sie was dann passiert ist das
was wir gestern abend am rande unserer
wahlrat hier erlebt haben das wir nur in
gefahr von leib und leben aus dieser
wahl partie überhaupt rauskommen dass
selbst meine lebensgefährtin und ihre
tochter tätlich attackiert werden von
demonstranten die diesen quatsch den
einiger sagen wie zum beispiel herr
gabriel und andere wie er sein nazis
oder der ungeheuerlichkeiten mehr
das glauben offensichtlich unbedachte
menschen und dann attackieren die
gewalttätig auf deutschlands straßen das
ist das ist im grunde genommen die saat
der gewalt die da von unseren
politischen gegnern gesetz wird wir sind
entsetzt darüber
wir sind eine zutiefst rechtsstaatliche
freiheitliche partei und wir wollen den
gepflegten demokratischen diskurs und
dann müssen die aufhören solchen einen
solchen sprachduktus an den tag zu legen
es gibt irgendwo grenzen und ich kann da
an die anderen parteien nur appellieren
diese grenzen einzuhalten
alles weitere jetzt aber zur
parlamentarischen arbeit von unseren
hörern des wahlkampfes entschuldigung
dass ich mich vor gedrängt hatte
die lösung ist alles richtig die erste
handlung die wir vollziehen werden im
deutschen bundestag ist deniz ii hrung
eines untersuchungsausschusses angela
merkel der sich ganz dezidiert mit den
rechtsbrüchen beschäftigen wird
ehemalige verfassungsrichter haben schon
konstatiert dass die kluft zwischen
rechten und wirklichkeit noch nie so
tief war in der bundesrepublik
deutschland und das ist auch der grund
warum wir diese aussage sehr ernst
nehmen von verfassungsrechtlern und das
einfordern werden dass man sich rein aus
der rechtlichen perspektive mit den
rechtsbrüchen in der euro
rettungspolitik aber auch in der
flüchtlingspolitik auseinandersetzen
wird
die nächste frage hörte daniel roland
erneuten versagen frau petra als
einzelperson hier aus der
bundespressekonferenz gelaufen
möglicherweise ich weiß es nicht hat sie
ja auch ein lager das noch hinter ihr
steht als er die frage
ja soweit die pressekonferenz der afg
die hier mit einem eklat begann es in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland wahrscheinlich einmalig dass
eine parteivorsitzende den rest der
partei und zukünftigen fraktionsführung
hier einfach in der
bundespressekonferenz sitzen lässt
erklärt dass sie nicht der fraktionen
der afg angehören möchte sondern als
einzel abgeordnete das kann sie ja
machen dem bundestag angehören möchte
das ist rechtlich völlig in ordnung denn
wir haben ja ein freies mandat jeder
gewählte abgeordnete kann selbst über
sich und seine zugehörigkeit zu einer
fraktion verfügen aber es ist trotzdem
ein einmaliger vorgang und dann auch
noch die pressekonferenz zu verlassen
du hast natürlich auch ein affront gegen
die journalisten der
bundespressekonferenz ist frauke petry
hat sich danach erklärt und gesagt sie
wolle eben einzelne abgeordnete bleiben
sie hat ja auch hier kritisiert dass in
der partei zu wenig erste
programmatische inhalte gegen sondern
dass zu viele abwegige äußerungen gerade
im wahlkampf stattgefunden hätte und die
parteien müssen sich einfach auf die
regierungsübernahme vorbereiten da steht
sie natürlich kreation zur fahrbahn der
mehrheitsmeinung in der partei und
zukünftigen fraktionsführung sie hat ja
ein direktmandat in sachsen gewonnen
eines von drei das ist ein großer
persönlicher erfolg möglicherweise hatte
er auch noch dazu geführt dass sie sich
jetzt dazu durchgerungen hat ihre eigene
partei und fraktion so zu brüskieren die
afg ist in sachsen ja stärkste partei
geworden
das gab es in einem bundesland bisher
nur von den grünen ansonsten in baden
württemberg ansonsten waren ja immer cdu
csu und spd die jeweils stärksten
parteien in einem bundesland nach den
grünen jetzt also die afd
in sachsen als stärkste partei ist ein
großer erfolg der möglicherweise auch
mit frauke petry zu tun hat das
komplizierte sache natürlich jetzt auch
aber mit diesem klar und auch mit diesem
affront hier hat frauke petry ja gezeigt
dass nicht nur die afg und ihre
politischen konkurrenten manchmal
unberechenbar sind sondern sie selbst
auch soweit hier aus der
bundespressekonferenz von dieser
pressekonferenz der afg zurück ins
fitnessstudio nach boden